are you on an island running towards me
Oh God hello I am NOT currently running
towards you
hello sergeant potato how are you
alright I'm gonna move on alright good
bye new friend I must go find other
friend you stay safe out there
oh I'm wet okay so you did see the red
tower though
well maybe oh no there's there could be
a lot of red towers okay how the [ __ ]
[ __ ] do I get out of here
I'm like drowning in the water right
look you're an F word I thought it was
gonna be like a profound sign like no
swimming in the water
oops I hear jingle bells jingle bells
that's just my bubbles I got small and
medium present on the ramp on the rape
on the rape oh I got a guy gets weird
how you have to unwrap one box like six
times yeah I just want to say that I've
got a good I don't even know if all well
okay that works
[ __ ] I can announced my position bo you
ringing the dinner bell there yeah let
the games begin where are you I'm the
receiving the data okay yes I'm awake it
appears to me completely pitch dark out
it is indeed it is dark [ __ ] awesome
turn on your torch let me see if I see
you
oh my torch is on well I see time to see
anything I'm at a house called genes
base nice do you see a lighthouse
that's the landmark that I see in the
distance not even at all not by a river
by a river or by a river right I don't
see a river yet let me know if you see
like a satellite dish no the moon is
above that does not help anybody but the
moon is right up there yep well I'm on
top of a very large mountain hill sort
of thing right now at a what appears to
be a quarry machine what do you see an
automatic
I don't see a lighthouse so [ __ ]
foggy that I'm high enough up that I
don't honestly see anything don't do
drugs kids oh yeah of course
well [ __ ] alright so I made of an
extremely wide section of river ah so
you are near a river then yes alright
your torch still on her yep I'm on the
come on the bank right now with my torch
on okay I am very wide no lighthouse in
sight when you look at the lighthouse
the moon is like straight [ __ ] up
right now what how are we supposed to
[ __ ] find anything is there a light
like beaming from the line no it's just
a pillar
okay well because I see like a thing in
the distance that's that's a big pillar
lighthouse esque sort of shape uh-huh
does it have like looks like it has
glass at the top of it no it's all kind
of dark can't really tell what are you
is that a deer one shoot that deer deer
sneaked up I'm sneaking sneaking all
over this deer Oh Mitch nope didn't do
nothing to the deer okay that was a
waste of a shell yeah this is definitely
like a lighthouse kind of thing but I
don't know if it's the same one you were
seeing no was yours kind of like on the
water yeah it's it's in the middle of
the water on a little island oh yeah
mine also is that thing wait are we
looking at the same thing then I'm I'm
on the coast next to it down short do
you see like a little Hut well I'm about
to climb onto this thing I'm going yeah
I'm going very slowly I don't have my
torch out right now I'm in the water are
you swimming out to it yeah I'm walking
out here small so I'm gonna try and
climb up on this light lighthouse
structure oh no I think if you're
already climbing on it I don't think
we're in the same place no wall but I
how it's like a [ __ ] castle how are
you climbing on it I don't know it must
be different things that we're looking
at don't give up hope yet alright I
found the door yeah so we must be in
completely different places so how do we
make a [ __ ] bed well when you hit tab
you can go into crafting
in there there are things such as common
such as the like as the Iraq such as and
like Abed yeah bed roll sleeping bag
that's what I was looking for sleeping
bag only needs 30 yeah no I just there's
a searching I just search for a bed I
don't know it's at the it's it's towards
the bottom of it not quite the bottom
don't teach me just just do it okay Oh
guns gun sons you hear guns or you see
guns you found guns you found gun ring
guns hearing guns oh oh that's not good
I was just in my inventory and all of a
sudden it was all the sun's coming out
so that's nice so they can find me I'm
going door-to-door oh my I don't know
how to make cloth are you hearing the
guns no I'm not hearing the guns there's
like a serious [ __ ] gunfight going on
hmm oh there's there's hemp plants that
give you cloth what they look like I
don't know it's kind of like a little
Christmas tree on the ground it was in a
field there about there about person
height they're dark green the leaves
look like weed leaves and they give you
cloth might be doing a dumb thing right
now but I'm opening up some of these
cans to try and get like a crude oil oh
do you hear an airdrop no I see an
airdrop man I hear nothing
oh I see it it's a way in the distance
for me okay it's like right over me
right oh okay so I know its direction
you are but I've made I'm making a
sleeping bag like right now and
apparently I can gift it to someone
maybe stay away from that that airdrop
by the way yeah well I don't think it
actually dropped yet did it I didn't see
it drop anything I just see the plane
okay so over you you don't know it's way
still way in the distance okay so if I
know my things about this thing which
I'm sure you do what the [ __ ] did I just
do right clicked it and now it's gone
is it on your Hut oh yeah no way got it
I've got it dude obviously right click
is delete [ __ ] idiot
only I can craft an acoustic guitar that
seems like a thing you need mmm I can
grab some pants cumberly's [ __ ] stuff
I'm finding has food in it come on I'm
running towards that place that you said
you were over there I'm running in the
direction of the that the the that the
thing was flying oh you need rope got a
fuckload of rope oh I see I see the
snow-capped Mountain it is on top of
that [ __ ] so far it is so in the
distance wow they just came over the top
of the snow-capped Mountain okay good
why did you go up to the top of that
because that was the quickest way to go
in the direction that you are okay all
right Wow
this map is [ __ ] big my rock is
almost out of durability what the [ __ ]
do I do with my rocks I don't know what
we do when rock break I [ __ ] don't know
okay I'm almost at the base of the snowy
mountain whoa really
yeah me here too okay all right me
walking towards Mountain sea power line
you see power line power line no oh you
must be on the other side of it I'm
gonna I'm gonna come towards what I
think is your side but there might be
Wolves over here so this might be
released wolves wait okay I'm now seeing
another snow-capped mountain oh [ __ ] no
no okay this might be a snowcat hill oh
no it might be more of a hill I see a
bigger one that might be more mountain
esque okay but do you see at all in the
distance some power lines I see a very
tall lighthouse that looks like it's
glass on top [ __ ] what I'm not very
close to it hang on I think I know you I
think I'm still on the right Hill but I
think you don't see any power lines I
don't what I'm over the horizon is a
little bit obscured right now I'd like
about to come over a very small crest
I'm also still collecting hemp cloth and
stuff while I'm on my way I don't see
any power line continued going in this
direction
you said god you're hot or is that just
what I wish you would say I said oh no
but you can go with that one god I've
never said this to you before but you
have great tits man yeah I don't know
where you would be but you saw the
lighthouse wait power lines
I see power woo woo you do mr. Boehner
big ones or small ones very big oh yeah
do you see a broken one alright there's
a broken one that's what I'm next to
right now just follow those power lines
baby follow them away from the Sun
that's the way no wait maybe towards I
don't know ways where you are from sort
of they're sort of going alongside the
sauna system missile silo no no that's
not a Miss no I'm right I'm right by the
broker if you're facing if you're sort
of facing the snowy mountain yeah I'm
going directly towards the big power
line stuff from the snowy mountain I'm
in like kind of an opening right now or
it's like orange yellow grass and lots
of rocks I think I know where you are
yeah I'm headed to right towards that
direction I think we're about to make
contact I'm gonna turn off my censoring
just for this moment I can't wait yeah
all right I'm right by power lines I'm
not by a broken one but I'm getting very
close to power I see a ravine with brown
grass rocks sensor rings off baby going
in raw I've got a shoes on just for you
baby
wait so I see little ones and big yeah
that's good I'm by little in big I don't
see a broken is it a broken little one
or a broken big one it's a broken big
one I feel like we're so close they they
end it like a walled in town area no no
I have no idea what I see a broken I see
a big broken whoa Kay is it is it a big
broken one by a tree or is a big broken
one by itself oh it's it's near some
trees but it's sort of mostly by itself
okay alright are you near it I'm right
under it it's kind of its kind of by a
weird base situation where I feel like
we're close
come on come on come on not you not us
customers I win it I went around the
area I went I tried to find that Wald in
town you're talking about but I'm going
back to the power lines it the thing
about these power lines is they're
literally right next to a snow-capped
Hemphill Mountain yeah that's death
that's where I came from do you hear
this sound Wow huh you heard that no I
shot a gun oh [ __ ] yes I'm right by the
the one with the truck I'm coming you're
coming oh oh you were sort of over a
hill from where I was all right along
the power lines that run right by the
water I'm gonna fire again oh I see you
I see you that better be you okay wait
you did you just stop moving
hang on wait okay what we're okay is
that you nice tits Jesus turn off sensor
and see wait yeah see what I'll pack one
baby oh let me stand on this rock for
you hey God
yeah and that's that's just rubbery and
no why are you bald bald why am i what
bald wait that's why we all have no hair
the radiation exploded it off of us back
though wait where you're you I can see
like like hair growing in spots of like
you just you get close enough I can
still see the nips peering through oh my
god
oh yeah god yeah I don't want to do that
with you nothing personal oh okay that's
fine I understand doesn't have the same
okay but hey we found each other
all right 40 minutes in yeah we do we do
food no I
yeah you you should have cloth I'm just
gonna put it at left right there all
right I have enough
crafting a sleeping bag so that when we
inevitably die ou can come back to life
with just figured out how to give it to
literally if you hold use down on it
when you place it it's given to a friend
found each other yeah we finally did
jeez oh I'm crafting it right now I
forgot that it takes time to craft stuff
yeah look baby look I got a bow I'm a
provider I'm still you have a bow but
the arrow is coming out between your
pinkie and ring finger don't ask
questions hey brass the bow and who
doesn't have a bow hey you know what
yeah what that's fine with me I'm gonna
I'm gonna it did provide us small
amounts I'm gonna I'm gonna plant these
hemp seeds and hopefully they'll grow
into something later is that what these
are oh I've got lots of hemp seeds
friends yeah so I'm just planting a
whole bunch over there maybe they'll
grow maybe they won't
I'm just spam planting them over here I
don't know if they need water or what
but who [ __ ] cares yeah man we got
each other
I was pretty sure we were never going to
actually find each other really oh man I
had I had fears and doubts man man you
should always believe listen to this
hopeful music and just reach down deep
in your heart and believe you can be
something the hopeful desolate tones of
the xylophone company I have like a
haunting melodic piano you don't have
that no okay well I do so just imagine
that along with like one of the rocks
look like my rocks almost did it's like
they look like the rocks on the ground
but they're not quite like all the other
rocks on the ground okay no man this is
some rocks on the ground that you can
pick up you get a look at rocks man sure
okay this rusts the look at rocks game
where you look at rocks I guess that
it's true that it I do recall spending a
lot of time walking around be like can I
collect this yeah I remember smacking
bears in the ass with rocks before that
was the thing that happened no mine mine
mine mine
no mine mine mine too late it's mine
what a warmth this barrel you're gonna
have my god that is so loud earlier when
people found me it was because I had
just done this and someone was like oh
dumbass alright so what do we what are
we planning did I didn't even start the
episode okay there's a can of tuna and
an apple here do you need food I'm
actually starving are you starving I I
have some food I had a candy cane okay
I'm gonna drop this Apple came
sustenance is that good is that good for
you baby doesn't say I'm starving
anymore so is there any way for us to
like put a beacon on our lovely things
on the floor or if I get lost him I just
bone forever I don't know to be honest I
don't think we need to worry about that
because if we die we'll go back to it so
this one looks different we gotta get
out of this oh hi everybody my name is
markiplier and this is Bobbi so yeah
oh also you should smack the trees and
get wood did you get wood oh we get this
video to ten million like hundred
trillion likes please
I still have anything to smack the tree
with yeah you can't fist it you used to
be able to fist them now you can't fist
him anymore oh man oh it's not that's
not how I like it
I've got a machete found a machete I saw
another person and my instinct was just
like whoa run was it me it's still me
just like how I you're running in the
distance and I just see a little
pixelated blur wouldn't want any of
those boobs to flop out ooh a cave dude
come up here come up on the hill where I
was there's a cave coming
this could be our cave that's where dude
this can be our cave the our cave where
I can starve to death
oh my god turn over oh hey there it is
found I see you see me I'm coming from
you're right hello oh there you are here
okay come in my cave that's what I tried
I smashed my machete and danced rocks no
no these rocks are rocks nope it's all
fake and you guys got rocks
everybody got rocks I guess this is just
dirt these aren't right I've seen rocks
stupid yeah rocks look like sorry oh
Jesus scary sick cave this
reminds me of the forest sort of
horrible creature lives down here yeah
probably you remember the first the
horrible caves oh my god that's a drop
that we went come on dark over here wait
where'd you go over here oh hey oh my
god
all right um we're probably gonna die if
we go down here but I say we go down
here yeah it [ __ ] it why not
boo boo boo boo boo boo oh yeah all
right whoa big swinging junk hey yeah
it's pretty big and it swings pretty
hard the funny thing is it swings at 0%
come on it's just like this is like
filled with puzzles don't [ __ ] up dude
do you pay bills with skills how what
what is this cave oh my god did you see
that oh okay you have a light the
loading light you're going left or right
I'm gonna go right left seems like death
there's some light over here Oh what
happened here this like is there lore to
this game now dude I don't know what is
like this the underground community that
died because it dug too deeply in it so
lift you first you gotta get in it
[ __ ] oh no oh why didn't we think of
that you have to be in it oh come back
maybe it goes up and down something
tells me that's not how this works
Oh No oh it's coming back oh okay told
ya I knew I knew now wait so let's go
explore the other pathway now that we
knew yeah we're gonna take that up and
come out and be like that we don't need
to go back through the sleeping bag no
wait mark oh that is the way okay no but
when we die we'll go back to them and
then this will all be meaningless yeah
exactly
this is these tiles literally were just
dug by a huge [ __ ] worm probably also
is this just the same as the other room
yeah it's another lift so you want to
get in and try to get in with me stand
on my head okay this is a great my oh
God nope oh why thanks for having me um
it says zero
stable should I write it back down no no
no you stay up there it'll come back
down I'll come join you in a second if I
just break it and it doesn't come please
there's another lift so I think I'll
give it the old slam my crotch against
it affords interesting interesting point
we're not actually out of the cave up
here oh there's not even a light up here
it's just pitch-black nazies maybe we
shouldn't have done this huh super
valuable I don't know yeah I mean it's
not like we were trying to actually
build a base or survive or anything I
would come get me
oh god my screen is freaking the [ __ ]
out my god psychopath is just like no I
can't move it says you will die unless
you get help soon you didn't ride it
back down
no it's busy laughing I'm good and you
say oh well hey I mean I'm dead I'm
gonna I'm dead so I'm spawning in my
sleeping bag I'm spawning at Bab stack o
is growing you see that so thank you
everybody so much for watching we [ __ ]
up real bad but that's okay because I
didn't even do an intro so but that's
okay you can forgive us right guys so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always we will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]